I wouldn't go on YouTube let's go ahead
and talk about this [ __ ] for a second
goddammit but I meant perform as you get
older you tend to meet a lot more people
now when you do there's a lot of people
out there that will cash judgment upon
you now some new type of people that
I've met recently or what we call wine
snobs you don't want to [ __ ] your wine
snob is a wine snob is somebody that
every time they drink wine they gotta
talk about why they like them on mmm is
wine it has an oaky aftertaste
especially people that talk about why
nowadays you glove with them
[ __ ] you never drink wine you
don't know [ __ ] I did the worst part
about these type of people they always
have to show you how intelligent is
smart they are because they know the
type of wine that they're drinking you
nearly not the valley 1982 yes really
you got that good of a [ __ ] nose when
you smell something you know the exact
date that he was [ __ ] brewed [ __ ]
you don't know [ __ ] why not spread my
[ __ ] butt cheek smell my butthole you
tell me what hospital olive born at
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] without going
[ __ ] so crib ate a lot of kimchi
goddammit yes yes yes Pepsi I don't have
a problem people who I want if that I
like wine makes me feel fancy huh dick
you think for a goddamn seconds and I'm
gonna let you look down on me because I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm drinking
you must be out your mind cuz we all
know that you are bullshitting at the
time just the other week I had a friend
know who the [ __ ] you are
well sin then talk about the wine that
he likes why is such a better one that
he's treating your pears and stuff that
I'm drinking and I'm looking at him like
but you don't know [ __ ]
this [ __ ] went to the bathroom I
switched his wine out with mine he drank
it and then I asked so what so great
about your wine again welcome tasting
and smelling it actually has a great
behind wait stick [ __ ] you don't know
[ __ ] that's why I'm a petty [ __ ]
I could [ __ ] about the [ __ ] that I'm
drinking right now and make it sound
believable it's not that hard for
anybody else out there they're trying to
drink this [ __ ] and then act like they
know what they're doing you just got to
use a few choice words oh it has a lot
of money in this oaky afterbirth it's so
fragrant the flavor profiles are similar
to the last glass of wine with this one
has a little bit something different
there's a lot of character see that nama
why experts to a [ __ ] kill yo
there you know what it I'll give it to a
certain amount of people some people
it's their profession it's their life
it's everything about them is just why
all those ghetto [ __ ] and you
offer that it probably had about three
different variations and now they're a
[ __ ]
esperan but you don't know the
difference between a chicken nugget and
a [ __ ] sticker you have the worst
taste buds on earth what are you talking
about I feel like you pseudo wine snobs
- they drink wine and talk about it
because it makes them feel good about
themselves
it actually makes them feel like they're
smarter but let me ask you this what the
[ __ ] is what your drinking had to do
with your intelligence acting like you
smart [ __ ] you can't even pronounce
half the [ __ ] that you're drinking
oh the pinup grittier a little bit of
champ at me beside me gone blank you
illiterate ass [ __ ] before you
even think about pronouncing wine why
don't you get past the alphabet talk
about you smarter you're so [ __ ]
stupid you got confused when you look at
a bowl of alphabet soup I'm a huge
advocate of being yourself if you don't
know [ __ ] no station and if you don't
know about the things that you're
talking about go ahead and go let it
bake until you make it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I go fake nothing mother
[ __ ] off stupidest out when it comes to
wine people talking about it here at
this wine it's sweet [ __ ] you
know what else is sweet juice